aquí en la reacción a esta noticia desde
conmoción de grandísima tristeza de
incredulidad la noticia tuvo aquí el
efecto de un relámpago de un trueno
muchos no querían ni siquiera creer en
esta en esta muerte de maradona que
consideran como el jugador de fútbol más
importante de todos los tiempos en
particular en la ciudad de nápoles una
ciudad en donde pasó un momento muy
importante de su carrera deportiva en
los 80s maradona llevó al equipo napoli
que en esa época era considerado un
equipo sin ambiciones pues maradona lo
llevó a ganar los más importantes
reconocimientos de su historia hasta
hacerlo transformarse en uno de los más
importantes equipos de fútbol europeos
ganó dos scudettos de la del campeonato
italiano en 1987 y en 1990 y esta noche
pues te puedo decir los napolitanos
están llorando por la desaparición de
maradona en las calles de nápoles ya se
ve una avalancha de reacciones de
desconocidos habitantes que muchos
consideran que una parte
la ciudad ha muerto en el día de hoy con
la desaparición de maradona hay que
saber que este jugador argentino era
considerado en esta ciudad casi como un
dios un icono una leyenda se le había
inclusive dedicado un museo a sus éxitos
deportivos y a su vida que
desafortunadamente pues se concluyó hoy
con este paro cardíaco a los 60 años
natalia y usted nos estaba diciendo que
precisamente maradona es considerado un
personaje sumamente importante en el
país y sumamente importante en nápoles
que se han producido reacciones bastante
importantes bastante fuertes cuéntenos
que ha tenido alguna posibilidad de
hablar con personas que le hayan dicho
que sienten ante esta pérdida para el
mundo
pues sí muchos italianos aquí consideran
que esta es una gran pérdida no sólo
para el deporte sino para en general
para la cultura deportiva mundial
maradona era considerado como un jugador
que que logró ir más allá de las
fronteras geográficas de las fronteras
de los países de las fronteras del
tiempo porque él logró quedarse en los
corazones de los italianos por muchos
años él estuvo acá jugando en el napoli
en los años 80 y todavía hoy es
inmensamente recordado y llegó esta
noche en nápoles te puedo decir una gran
tristeza y una gran conmoción por la
desaparición de esta leyenda del fútbol